so our goal in this video is to take the
antiderivative of this fairly
crazy-looking expression or another way
of saying it is to find the indefinite
integral of this crazy-looking
expression and the key realization right
over here is that you this expression is
made up of a bunch of terms and the
indefinite integral of the entire
expression is going to be equal to the
indefinite integral of each of the terms
so this is going to be equal to we could
look at this term right over here and
just take the indefinite take the
indefinite integral of that 7x to the
third DX and then from that we can
subtract the indefinite integral of this
thing so we could say this is and then
minus the indefinite integral of five
times the square root of X DX and then
we can look at this one right over here
so then we could say plus the indefinite
integral of 18 square root of x square
roots of x over X to the third DX and
then finally and I'm running out of
colors here finally I need more colors
in my thing we can take the
antiderivative of this so plus the
antiderivative of X to the negative 40th
power DX so I've just rewritten this in
color-coded things so let's take the
antiderivative of each of these and
you'll see that we will be able to do it
using our whatever we want to call the
inverse of the power rule or the anti
power or whatever you might want to call
it so let's look at the first one so we
have we have what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to find the antiderivative
without the constant just add the
constant at the end for the sake of this
one just don't we make sure we get the
most general antiderivative so here the
exponent is a 3 so we can increase it by
1 so it's going to be X to the fourth
it's let me do that same purple color or
the pink color it's going to be X to the
fourth or we're going to divide by X to
the fourth so it's X to the fourth over
4 is the antiderivative of X to the
third and you just had this scaling
quantity the 7 out front so we can still
just have the 7 out front so we get 7x
to the fourth over 4 fair enough from
that we're going to subtract the
antiderivative of this
now at first this might not be obvious
that this you could use our inverse
power rule or anti power rule here but
then you just need to realize that five
times the principal root of X is the
same thing as so this is the same thing
as five times X to the one-half power
and so once again the exponent here is
one-half we can increment it by 1 this
is going to be X to the three halves and
then divide by the incremented exponent
so divided by three halves and of course
we had this five out front so we still
want to have the five out front
now this next expression looks even
wackier but once again we can simplify a
little bit this is the same thing let me
do it right over here this is the same
thing as 18 times X to the one-half
times X to the negative 3 power X to the
third and the denominator is the same
thing as X to the negative 3 we have the
same base we can just add the exponents
so this is going to be equal to 18 times
X to the 2 and 1/2 power 2 and 1/2 power
or another way of thinking about it this
is the same thing as 18 times X 18 times
X to the 5 halves power to the 5 halves
power did I do that right yeah negative
3 oh sorry this is negative 2 and 1/2
let me make this very clear and this is
going to be the negative 5 halves power
X to the negative 3 is the same thing as
X to the negative 6 halves negative 6
halves plus 1/2 is negative 5 halves so
once again we just have to increment
this exponent so negative 5 halves plus
1 is going to be negative 3 halves so
you're going to have X X to the negative
3 halves and then you divide by what
your exponent is when you increment it
so divided by negative divided by
negative 3 halves and then you had the
18 out front and we obviously are going
to have to simplify this and then
finally our exponent in this term let me
not use that purple anymore our the
exponent in this term right over here
is negative 40 if we increment it we get
X to the negative 39 power all of that
over negative 39 and now we can add our
constant now we can add our constant C
and all we need to do is simplify all of
this craziness so the first one is
fairly simplified we can write it as 7/4
X to the fourth now this term right over
here is essentially negative five
divided by three halves so five over
three halves is equal to five times
two-thirds which is equal to ten over
three so this thing right over here
simplifies to negative ten over three X
to the three halves and then we have all
of this craziness now 18 divided by
negative three halves 18 divided by
negative three halves is equal to 18
times negative two-thirds which is equal
to well we can we can simplify this a
little bit this is the same thing as six
this is the same thing as six times
negative two which is equal to negative
twelve so this expression right over
here is negative 12 X to the negative
three halves and then finally this one
right over here we can just rewrite it
as if we want we could well we can't
write negative 130 ninths X to the
negative thirty nine plus plus C and
we're done
we found the indefinite integral of all
of this craziness and I encourage you to
take the derivative of this and you can
do it using really just the power rule
to take the derivative of this and
verify that it does indeed equal this
expression that we took that we took the
antiderivative of